when you look at what's happened over
the last 24 hours in ukraine and look at
what
how this war is progressing
do you
feel that slovenia is potentially a
future state at risk
first of all uh good afternoon
especially to you
reporting from the very
sensitive danger zone
yes we are all at risk because if
ukraine is taken by putin
then
this is not the end we
know this from the history europe is now
in the same situation as europe was
at 19 uh
when poland was attacked
if hitler was stopped at the at that
point
the europe
hadn't faced six years long second world
war
it's as crucial as this and we have to
be aware so defending ukraine is also
defending europe and it's also defending
slovenia
do you fear this is the end for an
independent ukraine
well first of all i think that what's
going on in in ukraine this is massive
suffering and
in slovenia
we
we know how they feel because 30 years
ago we were in the same situation for 10
days only
then we prevailed but
we were attacked by the yugoslav
communist army
we which
behaved very
like russian armies became now in
ukraine we knew what will happen when
the aggression started and i think that
we have to do everything
to help ukrainians to defend themselves
we have to help the refugees and we have
to to give them hope this is why we
launched the initiative to take them
into european union as
fast as possible this is not about the
procedures now it's about the hope
giving to the people
uh giving them feeling that they belong
to our family giving them strength to
defend themselves telling them
you are part of us
we
we will do everything we can to help you
to defend you you're also fighting for
europe
[Music]
yeah and that is something that i think
is mirrored in in all the other
countries that are taking in these large
numbers of refugees and there seems to
be so much generosity from so many
people in so many parts of the world
towards them
aside from the humanitarian aid that
many people are giving what about the
reaction of nato
do you feel it has been strong enough
well
nato is an alliance responsible firstly
to defend their own
our own members
and
currently this is happening
nato hasn't been
so much united as it is now
i don't think
in any time since the end of the cold
war
but it's not enough according to my
opinion we have to
it's it's uh it's uh proper that nato is
not directly involved in the conflict
with the with the
troops on the ground
but currently we have to do everything
to strengthen the air defense of the
ukraine
ukrainians are asking us to introduce
the non-fly zone
some of our friends are very afraid to
do this
there are reasons behind
this position
i proposed to
introduce no-fly zone
in ukraine before the conflict started
if this has happened
then
russia
would take all risk with starting the
war with the nato
in practice maybe this is not so simple
but now
there are two options
uh regarding introducing the non-fly
zone in ukraine first we have to be
aware this is ukraine this is not
russian
if this no-fly zoning is introduced in
ukraine
then this is uh on the call of sovereign
leadership of this country
and russia has no according to the
international law russia has not saying
it this is not speaking this is not
talking about introducing the nonfly
zone about russian territory this would
be
this would be threat to russia and this
would be a real uh
start of the of the conflict
theoretically in practice situation is
different
and i think that nato has to
do everything to strengthen the air
defense of the ukrainian army of the
ukrainian air forces
nato
nato actually has means to do this
it will take longer
and as you said
recently
there is also a possibility to to
introduce
limited uh non-fly zone
to
to
serve
the humanitarian purpose only i think
that
with the combination of uh these two
last approaches
we can help ukrainians a lot we can help
ukrainians a lot and with helping
ukrainians
we are helping to to defend
europe imagine if ukraine country of 40
million is taken
and we do nothing
real enough to help them
what
those who are against
helping to ukraine will say
when putin will
go further to moldova georgia
baltic states
the same people will say
oh
this is only one small country of 2
million people why to risk war
with
with
russia which is nuclear power
this is the same debate
as has happened in the 30s of the last
century and we all know what
were the consequences
so so time to be very serious time to
react is now
and i'm very glad that i see
the unity
inside of the european union and also
inside of the nato
which we have never faced during last
three decades
and this is giving hope not only to me
and to the slovenians and other nato
members especially those who are on the
border with the with the war zone now
but also to the ukrainians this is
this is the place where strength for
them is coming
janez yanska the slovenian prime
minister a pleasure to talk to you today
and thank you for explaining what people
of slovenia feel about this thank you